>>> IN OUR WORLD LEAD RIGHT NOW,
CONTRASTING VIEWS ABOUT A
90-MINUTE PHONE CALL BETWEEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN AND CHINESE
LEADER XI JINPING.
THIS IS THE SECOND TIME THE TWO
HAVE SPOKEN SINCE PRESIDENT
BIDEN ENTERED THE WHITE HOUSE.
THE CALL WAS DESCRIBED AS CANDID
IN TONE BUT NOT LECTURING OR
CONDESCENDING, AND THAT HUMAN
RIGHTS AND THE ORIGIN OF THE
CORONAVIRUS WERE AMONG THE
TOPICS.
BEIJING SAYS PRESIDENT XI TOLD
BIDEN THAT U.S. POLICY TOWARDS
CHINA HAS, QUOTE, CAUSED SERIOUS
DIFFICULTIES AND RELATIONS AND
RUNS COUNTER TO THE BEST
INTERESTS OF BOTH COUNTRIES AND
TO THE WORLD.
THE TOUGH TALK FITS RIGHT IN
WITH STEPS PRESIDENT XI HAS
TAKEN RECENTLY TO ASSERT CHINESE
NATIONALISM AT HOME AND ABROAD.
AND AS CNN'S DAVID CULVER
REPORTS FOR US NOW, THIS HARKENS
BACK TO PAST CRACKDOWNS ON
WESTERN INFLUENCE.
>> Reporter: CHINA'S RULING
COMMUNIST PARTY, HAVING JUST
CELEBRATED ITS 100th BIRTHDAY,
IS IMPLEMENTING A SERIES OF
DRASTIC POLICIES, UPENDING
EVERYTHING FROM MULTIBILLION
DOLLAR BUSINESSES TO POP
CULTURE.
>> IT'S BACK TO SOCIALISM.
AND THE PARTY, I THINK, WANTS TO
REMAIN AHEAD OF THE CURVE.
>> Reporter: SOCIALISM WITH
CHINESE CHARACTERISTICS, AS IT'S
CALLED HERE, THEY RETURN TO,
QUOTE, SERVING THE PEOPLE LED BY
AN INCREASINGLY POWERFUL XI
JINPING.
>> HE REALLY WANTS A DISCIPLINED
REGIME, A DISCIPLINED PEOPLE ALL
DEDICATED TO THE PARTY, IN MANY
WAYS, AND MAKING CHINA STRONG.
>> Reporter: AND IT MEANS
WEAKENING SOME OF THE COUNTRY'S
BIGGEST TYCOONS.
THEY HAVE TARGETED TECH GIANTS.
IT'S COINCIDED WITH RESTRICTIONS
ON MATERIALISM AND THE FLAUNTING
OF LUXURIOUS LIVING.
PRESIDENT XI HAS GONE A STEP
FURTHER CALLING FOR A
REDISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH TO
CLOSE A WIDENING INCOME GAP.
>> IT MEANS THAT BUSINESSES ARE
GOING TO BE MUCH MORE UNDER THE
CONTROL OF THE GOVERNMENT AND
THE PARTY.
IT MEANS THAT THE RICH ARE GOING
TO BE ALSO MUCH MORE UNDER
CHECK.
>> Reporter: THE CRACKDOWN HAS
ALSO EXTENDED TO CHINESE
CELEBRITIES, THOSE ACCUSED OF
TAX EVASION OR SIMPLY BEING
UNPATRIOTIC AND SOMETIMES EVEN
WITHOUT EXPLANATIONS NOT ONLY
CANCELED BUT ALSO ERASED FROM
CHINESE SOCIAL MEDIA AND ONLINE
STREAMING PLATFORMS.
>> YOU CAN'T GET TOO HIGH, YOU
CAN'T GET TOO FAMOUS AND YOU
CAN'T GET TOO WEALTHY.
>> Reporter: SOME ARE CALLING IT
A NEW CULTURAL REVOLUTION, HEART
ATTACKING BACK TO THE '60s AND
'70s WHEN THEN COMMUNIST LEADER
MAOZEDONG LED A MOVEMENT.
CRACKDOWNS ON FREE THOUGHT, MASS
IMPRISONMENTS AND DEATH.
IN TODAY'S CHINA THERE IS NO
QUESTION WHO'S IN CHARGE.
>> A COMMENT BY XI HAS MASSIVE
CONSEQUENCES NOWADAYS BECAUSE
THE BUREAUCRATS, THE PARTY
OFFICIALS TODAY ARE EAGER TO
PLEASE HIM, ARE EAGER TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON HIS INSTRUCTIONS
NOWADAYS.
AND THAT'S ACTUALLY FARED ALSO
IN THE CAPITAL MARKETS AS WELL.
>> Reporter: AND IT SPREAD INTO
CHINA'S ALREADY HEAVILY
PATROLLED CYBER SPACE, FROM
CELEBRITY FAN PAGES TO
UNIVERSITY LGBTQ GROUPS,
PROFILES FROM PAST POSTS
DELETED.
THESE POLICIES TO PURIFY THE
INTERNET AND PRESERVE PARTY
CONTROL SEEMING TO TARGET ANY
PERSON, COMPANY, OR GROUP WITH
SUSPECTED FORWARD INFLUENCE,
MOST ESPECIALLY FROM THE UNITED
STATES.
CHINA'S ALSO CHALLENGING THE
U.S. FOR FULL CONTROL OF
STRATEGIC SUPPLIES, FROM
ELECTRONIC CHIPS TO SOLAR PANELS
TO VACCINES.
IT WANTS ACCESS TO THESE KEY
ITEMS UNIMPEDED BY WESTERN
NATIONS AND EVENTUALLY TO BECOME
SELF-SUFFICIENT.
MEANTIME, SOME ARE TAPPING INTO
CHINA'S RISING NATIONALISM, BY
PROMOTING PATRIOTISM, MORALITY,
AND MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE, A
COMMUNIST PARTY IDEOLOGY.
STARTING WITH CHILDREN AS YOUNG
AS 6 YEARS OLD WITH THE RECENT
INTRODUCTION OF A NEW MANDATORY
ACADEMIC SUBJECT, XI JINPING
THOUGHT.
THE CHINESE PRESIDENT ALREADY
ELIMINATED TERM LIMITS IN 2018,
OPENING THE DOOR FOR HIM TO RULE
FOR LIFE.
AS FOR THE COMPANIES THAT ARE
FEELING GROWING SQUEEZE FROM
BEIJING, THEY'RE SUDDENLY PAYING
IT FORWARD IN A VERY PUBLIC WAY,
PLEDGING TO DONATE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO FURTHER XI'S SOCIAL
CAUSES, WHETHER VOLUNTARY OR
COMPELLED, IT SEEMS THEY HAVE
GOTTEN THE PARTY'S MESSAGE.
IN CHINA, THERE IS ONLY ONE BOSS
WHO REALLY COUNTS.
>> JAKE, THE CRACKDOWNS WE'RE
SEEING PLAYING INTO AN OBVIOUS
RESTRUCTURING OF BOTH SOCIAL AND
HOME LIFE.
A PURIFICATION OF THE PARTY WITH
THE GOAL FOR BOTH